President Trump has decided to speak in
the Super Bowl President Trump has
decided not to take part in the
traditional presidential super bowl
interview he's not gonna do it yeah
partly Trump is worried he might not
pass the NFL's concussion protocol I see
four fingers I see four yeah who's the
president I don't know sir here's a
mirror not that guy speaking of trumpets
come out that president Trump's director
of communications hope Hicks may have
partially obstructed justice yeah Trump
said he's furious with Hicks cuz he
hired her to fully obstruct justice
you don't go half way on these things
you go all the way
[Applause]
today is the first day of Black History
Month yeah yeah which is why president
Trump gave a shout-out to his three
favorite black people ben Carson Omarosa
and ben Carson he's working on it he'll
get their wisdom in this a big story I
got to talk about it the preserved
forearm the preserved forearm of a 16th
century Saint is on a tour across Canada
yes and get this get this tickets are
still available I hear about I hear
about that tour and I think imagine the
groupies just a bunch of groupies
hanging around in the lobby
you